ukulele is the spiritual successor to
banjo kazooie we never thought we'd get
but after a successful Kickstarter it's
totally happening and developer play
tonic has just released the first proper
trailer now that we've seen the game in
action we know a little bit more about
the gameplay the levels and the
all-important release date the core of
ukulele involves the titular characters
using various abilities to collect items
Yuka will be able to breathe fire and
shoot ice crystals from his mouth he and
Leila can also turn invisible to pass
certain obstacles and morphed together
into special objects like flowers the
trailer also gave us a glimpse of
several levels a mountainous region with
minecarts a snowy castle and underwater
chamber with pipes and some sort of neon
arcade and it's probably going to get
much crazier than that when the game
releases speaking of which ukulele has
been pushed back to q1 2017 play tonic
says they're delaying the game to get a
few more months of Polish beyond the
original November release date in any
case the game will release on ps4 xbox
one wii u and pc to keep up with all the
ukulele updates keep it locked to
gamespot
[Music]